The jogan Experience before we wrap up I
got to say one one more thing okay we
got to we got to give credit to Jelly
Roll I love that guy I love jelly roll
no we talked about him last time and I
think we've even listening to his songs
but I finally saw him live oh he's
amazing at the auy he was like the
[__] I mean I could if I think about
how nice he
is I would I could almost I I don't want
to say I'm going to cry but it's like he
is so nice dude a he treated me like
family yeah I mean he was we went out to
dinner and then even after the show he's
just like he goes what what' you think
of my family I mean he cares yeah he is
such a big-hearted person and I'm it was
amazing how welcoming and kind and
thoughtful and puts on an amazing show
talks to the people like makes people
cry when he's talking to them in between
songs cuz he's so heartfelt yeah he's
been through so much but he's like I
don't is you and him and Nelly that's
awesome and I don't know how you know I
don't know how he was back in the day
you know but all I know is I know he
made mistakes I know he's been in jail I
know he's whatever but now I don't know
a nicer more I don't know a better
person yeah he's been through a lot he's
he's incredible came on the other end an
amazing person he's [__] nominated
for two Grammys I know
what a journey what a journey I mean I
just just look at him like you would
never look at that guy when you hear him
sing you're like whoa no and what you
know Tanner mentioned this too he's when
people first see him they're like oh you
know he's got tattoos on his face Tanner
says after you get to talk he goes you
don't even see the tattoos right you see
you see this this pure Soul yeah and
like T what tattoos I [__] don't see
[__] so like you get distracted by that
at first but when you talk to him and
realize you know what a loving person he
is you're just like I don't see anything
I I see just this big-hearted man that's
the same thing with post Malone yeah
yeah you got to meet him he's amazing I
love that dude to death he's so [__]
talented too we saw him perform in
Houston my wife and I flew to Houston to
watch one of his shows really oh was and
then we were hanging out with him
afterwards he wants to play Magic the
Gathering I don't know those artists I
just I don't know there's different
people but they're so I don't know it's
is pretty inspiring yeah he's very
inspiring U when he gave me that
platinum record and we posted out there
you saw believe I did incredible
incredible great gift well here and
here's another thing too he said when he
was a kid he used to dream about having
records like that you know like have it
all and and he goes now he goes now he
goes what I want so we went to the show
at the Opry but then the next day I I
had to go oh train with Rich but then he
said you know can you meet for lunch at
so house or whatever and I said yeah so
he's like I want you to sign my book
he's like because or your book he had my
endure book and he's like I used to
think that I wanted records on the wall
he goes but now I want a book signed by
you that's that's what I want and he had
like gloves from uh I think a fight um I
can't remember whose gloves like UFC
gloves but it's like it's that's what
means something to him now not the
personal accolades but I just God I
can't I can't talk enough positive about
that guy such he's such a warm Soul the
first time I met him I met him at the
Mother Ship he came there to see Ron
White and I was uh that was when the
club had first opened and I was kind of
there just hanging out making sure
everything was running right because we
had just gotten open and then uh they
said hey jelly rolls here to see Ron
White and then uh you know where the
Green Room is at the club he was coming
up the stairs and I was walking out and
I saw him and he just goes what's up
he's just big giant hug I'm like oh my
God this guy's everything I hoped he
would be he's amazing uh there's
beautiful people in the world man you
know you meet them he's one of them they
change the way you feel about the way
you interact with people and I he he
makes me I I that's what I said when I
got home it makes me want to be a better
person yes because I saw how he treated
everyone like there'd be people on the
sidewalk and there'd be like you know
these little old old women and are not
old probably my age [__] what am I
talking about but like so like caught
off guard like oh my God jelly roll's
here and he's like what's up mama how
you doing how you doing tonight give him
a big hug just like looking him in the
eye and just the sweetest person just
some some person walking by yeah because
that's a guy where life gave him a
[__] terrible hand and he got through
it and he came out on the other end and
now he's amazing you know now it's like
this amazing journey that he can like
really truly appreciate every aspect of
it and he's so good at expressing that
he's so good at spreading that love
spreading that positivity and it really
does make you want to be a better person
it makes me want to be a better person
both him and post they make me want to
be nicer to everybody I yeah I've never
I try real hard to be nice to everybody
you do a great job you do you do amazing
job but it's like you don't do as good
as
him it's like there's there's levels
there's levels to everything it's just
like he his I think his eyes are just so
kind too cuz it's like what I see and we
said this the last time but like you see
the pain he's you see pain in his eyes
still a little bit yeah or I do yeah and
or I don't know you see it in his music
you hear it hear it you hear it for sure
you can't be that Soulful unless you've
experienced some dark dark dark times I
mean there's some you know there's some
magic to the way he sings that I just
don't you don't get that from a trust
fund baby you get that from a hard life
man and coming out on the other side as
this like beautiful creation of love and
and creativity and that's that dude
that's the real thing man you know
that's not an act that's him 247 and
it's amazing and it's very inspirational
and it's it's very good for everybody
it's good for everybody it's for good
for everybody he encounters he was like
you know he was so busy after the show
and they had to do a promo stuff at at
the after the opery so we took off
and then he told me he's like he goes oh
he goes I didn't you know I didn't get
to say goodbye to Tanner I took Tanner
to the show and his girlfriend and he's
like I said I think you said goodbye
he's like oh I didn't give him like a
good hug to say goodbye he's like I mean
thinking about even that I know just
about my son it's just there he is see a
speech at the end oh did did you see
let's play this we we can end with this
speech cuz this speech is [__]
incredible um I think it's C up got a
second and I'm going to say say a lot
and I'm sorry but the quickest I can say
it is thank you to the label Stony Creek
Management John Loa Joe Jamie you saved
my life country radio what's up
baby I got a thousand people to thank
you but most importantly my Lord and my
wife I love you so much you changed my
life
baby Megan Parker Haley I love all y'all
we're friends and Zack Brown I think you
were one of the hottest things on Earth
not this country music you deserve as
much as anybody else I love you I'm glad
we're sitting there partying the rest of
the night baby but most importantly
there is something poetic about a 39y
old man winning new artists of the year
I don't know where you're at in your
life or what you're going through but I
want to tell you to keep going baby I
want to tell you success is on the other
side of it I want to tell you it's going
to be okay I want to tell you that the
windshield is bigger than the real you
be a reason because what's in front of
you is so much more
important
[__] yeah [__] a
preacher